[Applaudissements]
j'ai tropiques fm qui m'appelle baba
montpetit baba je te lance un petit défi
barbares d'autres prends moi en tant
qu'experte médias juste une fois un jour
sur tpm paix avec vous tous
ça nous changera des youtube eu ce qu'on
les miens followers mais qu'on jamais
allé mais la télé à savoir même si elles
en ont tu prends une fois et si je
relève le défi et si je m'en sors plutôt
pas mal tu viendra faire une émission
ici à tropiques fm avec moi qu'est ce
t'en dis tu es chaud tu dis oui
vous connaissez elle a dit des mots qui
sonnent bien sûr elle a dit les mots à
laver mes mots ouais c'est ça m'a rendu
accro comme des et sheryfa luna et bien
ludivine à sera experte médias dès la
semaine prochaine après l'émission avec
nous le tropique fm on entendra
tropiques fm et illies avec tout ce soir
elle est née à dijon c'est notre expert
en média du jour elle est magnifique
elle est sur tropiques fm
si vous aimez le tropicana si vous aimez
la fm adorait ce qu'il a fait c'est
ludivine
et au el haggar bombe atomique en douce
alors vous êtes animatrice sur tropiques
fm absolument ce débat très bien et vous
nous avez lancé un appel un défi un défi
est bien le défi relevé puisque vous
êtes avec nous ce soir
notre experte médias
[Applaudissements]